Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
Show and thank you for joining me. I am David
Pakman. If he was turned into a pumpkin
at midnight and then somehow for some
unexplained spiritual and magical reason,
didn't quite get turned back into himself.
I am Jessie, Delaware. I am the host of the
Dallimore Daily on YouTube and I doubt it.
Podcast. Wherever podcasts are found, they can
also be found on the Internet at dallimore,
on Twitter, Instagram and TikTok. Now that all
the shameless self-promotion is out of the way,
let's talk about a shameless self-promoter
himself, Jorge Santos. This entire saga of his
committee assignments and the subbed, the previous
lies that he's told have kind of culminated. And
he just resigned his committee assignments that
were granted to him by Kevin McCarthy. And I'm not
going to take it. I don't think you should take
it on face value. His his resignation from the
committees not standing up and being there for his
constituency, which is kind of been the that the
timber and the tenor of his of his attitude up
to this point. I'm going to read a statement.
But then before I do, I want to talk about exactly
what is what is taking place among the Republican
caucus. It's become a revenge for higher outfit,
the Republican Party in the House. And they're
going to exact revenge upon Democrats for removing
Marjorie Taylor GREENE from her committees.
And they're going to do it by way of removing
Ilhan Omar, not allowing Ilhan Omar to be on
the Foreign Affairs Committee. For a number of
different reasons. Almost all of them are rooted
in racism, rooted in fear and bigotry and
xenophobia. We're going to get to all of
that. I got some clips. But first, let me read
this, the statement from Jorge Santos. And we
can we can talk about this and and kind of break
it down that this doesn't seem genuine to me. This
seems like an excuse that he was forced off of
his committees by Kevin McCarthy because maybe
maybe Kevin McCarthy knows something that the rest
of us don't know is something that's coming down
the pike, or just that this was to take creating
too much complication for the Republicans in their
quest to punish Ilhan Omar. Here's this Jorge
Santos, Republican of New York's third District,
issued the following statement requesting that
he be recused from both the House Committee on
Small Business and the House Committee
on Science, Space and Technology. Quote,
With the ongoing attention surrounding both my
personal and campaign financial investigations,
I have submitted a request to Speaker McCarthy
that I be temporarily recused from my committee
assignments until I am cleared, quote unquote,
said Congressman Santos. This was a decision that
I take very seriously. The business of the 118th
Congress must continue without media fanfare.
It is important that I primarily focus on
serving the constituents of New York's third
Congressional District and providing federal level
representation without distraction. Too late, bro.
Too late. It goes on. I want to personally
thank Speaker McCarthy for meeting with me
to discuss the matter and allowing me to take time
to properly clear my name before returning to my
committees. To my constituents, I remain committed
to serving the district and delivering results
for both New York's third Congressional
District and for the American people.
I don't think any of that is true. I think that
he is being forced off of his committees by Kevin
McCarthy for a number of different reasons.
At least two. I think this is my estimation
of it. When I worked for the Congress back in
the day, I worked for the United States Senate.
I didn't really have much to do on the House
side. But politics is politics. And I think
what's taking place here is Kevin McCarthy
either know something's coming down the line
that's going to force his hand or he knows that
this is complicating their racist xenophobia.
Mission to remove Ilhan Omar. Congresswoman Ilhan
Omar from her post on the Foreign Relations,
a foreign affairs committee. Now,
this was asked of Steve Scalise,
a leader in the House of Representatives, a
leader in the Republican Party, even though
years ago while campaigning. Steve Scalise said
that he's just like David Duke, except without all
the baggage. Steve Scalise, Just like the former
grand wizard of the KKK without all that baggage.
I always like to remind people what he said. He is
talking here about Congresswoman Ilhan Omar, and
he put the he juxtaposed against what Democrats
did to Marjorie Taylor GREENE by removing her
from her committees for things that she said
before she was even a congressperson. Watch
this. Since committees remove her from committee.
Speaker 2: Four resolution came up.
Yeah, obviously, we've we've been talking to
our members and and pointing out a lot of issues
because, you know, if you look at what we were
very concerned about last Congress with Democrats
removing Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Paul Gosar
from all of their committees. This is not the
same in a number of regards. Number one, they went
after Marjorie Taylor GREENE for things that she
had said before she was a member of Congress that
she denounced before she was a member of Congress.
It was very personal. And they removed her from
every committee. Even if Omar were to be removed
from the Foreign Affairs Committee, she'd still
be allowed to serve on other committees. So a lot
of big differences. And if Omar is concerned
about being removed, probably be good. If you
would ask her why she voted to remove Marjorie
Taylor, GREENE and Gosar from their committees,
because she did vote to do that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's because of
vile racism and terroristic goings on
relative to Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
Not full on terrorism, but stalking,
hounding, school, shooting victim survivors,
going to the Capitol. I'm going to play a clip a
little later of her going to the Capitol to find
Ilhan Omar, to get her to answer why she didn't
swear her, put her hand on the Bible, the holy
Bible, not the Koran, when she became a member of
Congress. It is a completely different thing. This
is hypocrisy run amok again. This is a revenge
fantasy being fulfilled by the Republican Party.
Now, some of my suspicions, I believe, will
become your suspicions as well. When you watch
Marjorie Taylor GREENE being interviewed,
what looks like in the in the crypt, in the
in the in the labyrinth beneath the Capitol by
reporters. And she kind of spills the beans that
Santos needed to go because of their
quest to remove Ilhan Omar. Watch this.
Speaker 3: There was so much drama
really over the situation, and
especially what we're doing to work to remove
Ilhan Omar from the Foreign Affairs Committee.
Mr. Santos statement in there was just
saying that he he spoke with Speaker
McCarthy and made this decision on his own.
Speaker 1: They're doing a lot of work to
try to convince you that George Santos made this
decision on his own. All while crying crocodile
tears about the prior the previous removal of
Marjorie Taylor GREENE for things that she said,
Martin was a congresswoman. Oh, my God. It
was so personal. It was. And here's the clip
I talked about earlier, her skulking through the
halls of the office buildings on Capitol Hill,
seeking out people to answer for their crime of
breaking the law. Now, it's not a law that someone
must put their hand on the Bible when they swear
in to Congress. This woman so stupid, so ignorant
of our faith traditions or requirements, lack of
requirements for faith traditions to be a member
of Congress, that she thinks you must swear on a
Bible. To become a member of Congress. Watch this.
Speaker 3: They signed it. They saw it on the
Koran. Oh, we have the Bible. We're going to
talk about swearing in honor of how to swear
in on the Bible with them and let them know
what our law says that you can't swear in on the
Koran. So we're going to explain that. You know,
we're going to explain about how you can't swear
in on the Koran. And we're going to have the Bible
and ask them if they would swear in on the Bible
that we really needed the oath. Yeah, we have
the oath. Yep. So I think that's important.
Speaker 4: The sad thing is, now that your
friends are in a religion which they you
should not be infringing on our religion.
Yes. By saying that we can't swearing.
Speaker 3: But when they swore in,
it wasn't a law yet. Right. So at the time they
swore. I don't know. I think at the time they
morning that wasn't cast well, because it
wouldn't have been passed in a Republican
controlled. Yes. So it was passed after they swore
in. So they're not really official, I don't think.
So let's go ask them to swear in and the
Bible, because like you said, well, I'm.
Speaker 4: It has to be the Holy Bible.
Speaker 3: Yeah. It has to be the Bible.
Speaker 4: Well, the bottom line is bottom
line is the law is not compatible with
America. Yep. That's the bottom line.
Speaker 3: That's the bottom line.
Speaker 4: How can you say you represent
women but you support Sharia law?
Speaker 1: This is the stunning
Kruger in rare, rare form.
So certain of herself that it
was against the law at some point
to use anything other than the Holy Bible to
swear on members of Congress for swearing on
Spiderman comic books or Superman comic books.
This Congress, you can swear on anything.
If I were a member of Congress, I think I'd
probably put my hand upon the Constitution of
the United States. Since you're also swearing
an oath to support and defend that document.
She's a member of Congress. And when they act
like, oh, this was so long ago, this was before
she was a Congress person. This was like two
years before she became a congressperson. She's
a 44 year old woman. She's a middle aged woman
skulking through the halls to teach her a lesson.
And the unfortunate thing is they're going
to get their way relative to Ilhan Omar.
Who's just a just a woman trying to do her
job, trying to represent her constituency.
But by all accounts, a loving and decent
person who has a heart for humanity but
not a Republican. And she is now in the
crosshairs, figuratively speaking, for now.
And they're going to exact
their revenge. Not great.